Wissenschaft Tod und
Verschwörungstheorien das ist die Insel
Riems in der Ostsee und der
gefährlichste Ort Deutschlands hier
forschen hunderte Wissenschaftler unter
Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit umringt
von Wasser riesigen Zäunen und wachen
die Öffentlichkeit durfte diesen Ort das
letzte Mal vor mehr als 10 Jahren
betreten aber was passiert auf dieser
Insel warum ist die Forschung
gleichzeitig so wichtig und so tödlich
und was passiert im berühmten S4 Bereich
die gefährlichste Forschung Deutschlands
genau darum geht es heute bei dr
Watson hey wenn ihr nach kreativen und
nachhaltigen Weihnachtsgeschenken sucht
dann haben wir was für euch verschenkt
doch eine Mitgliedschaft bei Planet wild
und somit die Renaturierung unseres
Planeten mehr Infos dazu gibt's am Ende
des Videos und da bekommt ihr auch noch
von mir was
geschenkt
1898 der Wissenschaftler Friedrich
Löffler erforscht den Erreger der Maul
und kauensche und damit erfindet er
nichts Geringeres als die Virologie aber
es gibt ein Problem seine Forschung ist
tödlich dort wo er forscht häufen sich
die Ausbrüche der solche durch
virenverschleppungen aus dem Labor immer
mehr Tiere werden krank was ja auch
irgendwie logisch ist denn niemand
wusste bis dato so richtig dass es Viren
überhaupt gibt und wie sie sich
verhalten auch löfler selbst hatte
anfangs nur Vermutungen seine Arbeit am
Festland ist also so gefährlich dass ihn
der St auffordert seine Forschung dort
zu machen wo die Tierwelt und
Bevölkerung nicht sind auf einer Insel
in der Ostsee RIS sie ist 1,3 km lang
und 300 m breit die einzige Verbindung
gibt es über eine Seilbahn später mit
einer Brücke jeder Mensch jedes Tier und
alles Andere was hier rein und raus geht
kann streng kontrolliert werden nichts
betritt oder ganz wichtig verlässt die
Insel wenn es eine Gefahr darstellt so
entsteht auf brst das Friedrich Löffler
Institut die weltweit erste virologische
Forschungsstätte heute arbeiten hier
unter den krassesten
Sicherheitsbedingungen über 800 Menschen
sie forschen unter Ausschluss der
Öffentlichkeit an der Prävention
Diagnose und Bekämpfung der schlimmsten
Krankheiten der Welt da gibt es
natürlich solche die ihr bestimmt schon
kennt z.B SARS oder die Vogelgrippe aber
es gibt auch noch den berühmt
berüchtigten S4 Teil des Instituts und
zu dem kommen wir gleich denn vorher
müssen wir stehen was die Forschung auf
rims so gefährlich macht das Institut
für neue und neuartige
Tierseuchenerreger kurz innt wenn eine
Krankheit sich nur von Tier zu Tier
übertragen lässt dann spricht man von
einer tiersäuche für Tiere ist das
logischerweise sehr gefährlich aber für
uns Menschen nur indirekt wir werden
zwar nicht krank aber wenn die Tiere
krank werden die wir essen fehlen uns
eben diese Nahrungsmittel ein noch
größeres Problem haben wir wenn eine
Krankheit nicht bei Tieren bleibt
sondern auch uns befallen kann das nennt
man dann
Zoonose das sind Infektionskrankheiten
die von Bakterien Parasiten Pilzen
Prionen oder Viren verursacht und
wechselseitig zwischen Tieren und
Menschen übertragen werden können beim
innt forscht man an beidem also an
tiersäuchen und zonosen und die Liste
der Erreger ist ziemlich lang alphaviren
Coronaviren bunaviren und noch vieles
mehr all diese Erreger werden auf riims
untersucht es werden Nachweismethoden
entwickelt und das dazu wird sich noch
damit beschäftigt wie die Krankheit
entsteht und verläuft und um
Infektionskrankheiten besser zu
verstehen muss man sie eben da haben auf
Rems finden sich also Erreger für die
Vogelgrippe für die Schweinegrippe
Corona und noch vieles mehr und jetzt
die wichtige Frage ist das nicht super
gefährlich und die Antwort ist Jin bei
einem Ausbruch könnte es zu Ansteckungen
von Tieren und Menschen außerhalb der
Labore kommen ja aber wenn ein solcher
Ausbruch ziemlich unwahrscheinlich ist
dann ist die Forschung ja wiederum
eigentlich sehr sicher und dafür
sprechen zumindest die ziemlich krassen
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen um ein Gefühl
dafür zu bekommen wie schwierig es für
einen Erreger wäre aus dem Labor
auszubrechen müssen wir uns die
Arbeitsbedingungen im S4 Labor anschauen
für die Krankheiten an denen hier
geforscht wird gibt es weder Impfstoffe
noch Therapien nach einer Infektion ist
man also seinem Schicksal ausgesetzt und
das kann fatal enden zu den Erregern in
S4 gehört z.B Ebola was in 30 bis 90%
der Fälle zum Tod führt das S4 Labor
befindet sich weg vom Rest des Instituts
in einem baulich abgetrennten Bereich
der Insel dort muss man durch drei
Schleusen mit einer druckkaskade gehen
die sorgt dafür dass im Labor ein
Unterdruck aufrecht erhalten wird der
sicher geht dass bei einer Undichtigkeit
keine Luft aus dem Labor entweichen kann
generell wird alles was an Luft rein und
rausgeht gefiltert dazu kommt dass das
komplette Labor gasdicht ist auch
sämtliches Abwasser aus dem Labor wird
chemisch und thermisch unschädlich
gemacht das alles stellt sicher dass
Erreger sich weder über die Luft noch
über Gas oder das Abwasser einen Weg
nach draußen suchen können okay aber was
ist mit den Tieren im Labor selber ist
natürlich alles womit geforscht wird
unter Verschluss Tierkörper an denen man
hier forscht werden im Labor beseitigt
sie verlassen also nie wieder den S4
Bereich und was ist mit den Menschen die
verlassen ja hoffentlich schon wieder
den S4 Bereich jeder der hier arbeitet
steht in Funkkontakt mit der Außenwelt
und vor dem Labor wartet immer Backup
Personal im Falle dass etwas schief
geheht und nach einem Besuch im S4 Labor
muss man sich einer chemiedusche
unterziehen um die Erreger abzutöten
ganz schön krass und auch irgendwie
paradox auf rims sind die tödlichsten
Erreger der Welt für die es keine
Heilung gibt das macht die Insel mega
gefährlich aber aus dem gleichen Grund
ist die Insel eigentlich super sicher es
ist also gleichzeitig vielleicht einer
der gefährlichsten und sichersten Orte
Deutschlands okay da gibt es aber noch
ein Problem gegen dass die meisten
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen nutzlos sind
sobald es einmal wissenschaftliche
Ergebnisse gibt ist die Box der Pandora
geöffnet Ergebnisse zu Erregern die
ganze Landstriche auslöschen können sind
dann im Umlauf und können für gutes oder
für schlechtes genutzt werden
Terroristen könnten z.B mit Hilfe von
Forschungsergebnissen Biowaffen bauen
und dafür müssen Sie nicht mal auf riims
einbrechen oder so das Wissen wird ja
mit der internationalen
forschungscommunity geteilt und ist mal
mehr und mal weniger leicht zugänglich
die tödlichsten Waffen der Geschichte
waren auch mal harmlose
wissenschaftliche Experimente z.B die
Kernspaltung aber ist das ein Grund
Forschung zu stoppen wenn sie potenziell
gefährlich eingesetzt werden kann hinter
dieser Frage steckt ja ein ethisches
Dilemma und das ist eins das
wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal jeden
Wissenschaftler und jede
Wissenschaftlerin beschäftigt in fast
allen Wissenschaftsgebieten besteht die
Gefahr dass Forschungsergebnisse und
Methoden die eigentlich mal gut gemeint
war
zu schädigenden Zwecken missbraucht
werden können man nennt das auch die
Dual use Problematik 2012 haben
Forscherinnen und Forscher gezeigt dass
vogelgripp viriren über Mutation die
Fähigkeit entwickeln können zwischen
Frettchen über die Luft übertragen
werden zu können und dafür gab es
einiges an Kritik nicht nur können diese
hochpathogenen also höchst krank maenden
Erreger bei einem Unfall nach draußen
gelangen sie könnten auch die Grundlage
für verheerende Biowaffen sein die
Forscherin und Forscher verteidigen aber
ihre Arbeit die Ergebnisse sind ein
Einblick in die Veränderung des Virus
unter welchen Umständen wird es zur
Bedrohung und mit diesem Wissen lassen
sich dann Viren einordnen und
Schutzmaßnahmen ergreifen finde ich
klingt relativ logisch 2016 stuft der
Direktor der amerikanischen
Sicherheitsbehörde NSA die genschere
Chris bquez 9 als mögliche
Massenvernichtungswaffe ein mit
neuartigem Gene editing kann man
theoretisch Viren erzeugen die unsere
DNA attackieren oder Killer Moskitos die
nahrungsmittelgrundlagen angreifen und
ja das sind alles sorgen die ich
verstehen kann aber gleichzeitig
ermöglichen uns genome editing Methoden
ungeahnte Möglichkeiten die unlösbare
Probleme in der Wissenschaft auf einmal
lösbar machen schaut euch dazu gerne
unser Video hier an und das ist kein
rein biologisch chemisches Problem
Fortschritte der kiforschung werden
gerade genutzt um neue Methoden zu
entwickeln die Welt zu einem besseren
Ort zu machen gleichzeitig werden sie
aber auch genutzt um um uns
auszuspionieren und Desinformation zu
verbreiten und Angst zu schüren also
falls jetzt von uns eine klare Antwort
erwartet wann gefährliche Forschung in
Ordnung ist und wann nicht dann muss ich
euch leider enttäuschen wir haben es
hier eben mit einem Dilemma zu tun es
gibt erstmal keine richtige oder falsche
Antwort aber natürlich beschäftigen sich
super viele Forscherinnen und Forscher
auf einer Metaebene mit genau diesem
Problem was ich da zumindest festhalten
lässt ist dass es wie so oft auch sehr
kompliziert ist Forschung im Hinblick
auf ihren Kosten Nutzenfaktor zu
bewerten man muss für jedes
Forschungsprojekt eine individuelle
detaillierte Analyse anfertigen um zu
entscheiden ob die Ergebnisse mehr vor
als Nachteile produzieren und das ist
wahnsinnig kompliziert wer hat am Ende
Zugang zur Forschung lassen sich
Ergebnisse zu militärischen oder
terroristischen Zwecken einsetzen gibt
es ungeahnte Konsequenzen einer
Entdeckung das ist alles schon schwierig
genug zu beantworten und dann kommt aber
noch eine zweite Achse ins Spiel Zeit
Forschung die jetzt gerade
unproblematisch ist kann in Zukunft
Schaden anrichten oder in Kombination
mit bisher unentdeckten Technologien von
etwas harmlosem zu etwas tödlichem
werden z.B wollte Albert Einstand
natürlich nie dass seine Forschung
genutzt wird um eine Atombombe zu bauen
auf einmal ist um die Forschung eine
moralisch ethische Diskussion bei der
man nicht nur die Interessengruppen in
der Gegenwart sondern auch Menschen die
noch nicht geboren sind berücksichtigen
muss und das ist nur ein Bruchteil der
Fr Fragen die sich die Expertinnen und
Experten stellen auch die Forschung auf
Riems kann man so sehen an diesen
Erregern zu forschen kann sehr
gefährlich sein aber wenn nicht daran
geforscht wird kann es im Zweifel noch
viel gefährlicher werden und das aus
zwei Gründen erstens wir haben alle
miterlebt was zu onosen wie z.B Corona
mit unserer Gesellschaft machen können
zwei Drittel aller neuen Krankheiten
sind zuonosen und ohne die Forschung
daran können Sie uns unvorbereitet
treffen und zweitens lässt sich nicht
aufhalten wenn wir hier uns dagegen
entscheiden an zu onosen zu forschen
wird es trotzdem irgendwo auf der Welt
jemand anderes machen nur dass wir uns
da nicht sicher sein können dass das
Wissen geteilt und mit denselben Werten
daran geforscht wird deswegen bin ich
persönlich sehr froh dass es die
Forscherinnen und Forscher auf rims gibt
die diese super wichtige Arbeit machen
genauso wie ich froh bin dass es
Menschen gibt die sich tagtäglich
konsequent für Naturschutz einsetzen und
das macht das Team von Planet wild und
eine mitgli hierbei könnt ihr jetzt auch
als Weihnachtsgeschenk verschenken
Weihnachten verkommt in meinen Augen
häufig zu einer sinnlosen konsumschlacht
mit Nachhaltigkeit hat das dann meistens
gar nichts mehr zu tun wenn euch das
auch zu blöd ist dann schenkt euren
Liebsten doch lieber etwas Naturschutz
mit einem solchen Geschenk könnt ihr
euch sicher sein dass es wirklich einen
positiven Effekt für den Schutz des
Planeten hat und nachhaltig ist den Link
dazu findet ihr unten in der
Beschreibung die rewilding Organisation
Planet wild aus Berlin führt nämlich
jeden Monat hat ein großes
Naturschutzprojekt durch um unseren
Planeten zu renaturieren und die Schäden
zu beheben die die Menschen der Natur
zufügen ihre Arbeit dokumentieren sie
dann immer in einem coolen youtube-
Video und finanziert wird das alles von
einer Community der jeder beitreten kann
der etwas für den Schutz unseres
Planeten tun möchte ich bin da übrigens
auch schon länger Mitglied und ich freue
mich immer sehr über die extrem coolen
Aktionen und jetzt habe ich noch ein
Geschenk an euch zu Weihnachten für die
ersten 200 Leute die eine Planet wild
Mitgliedschaft beantragen bezahlt ich
den ersten Monat klickt dazu unten auf
den ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung
und meldet euch an es ist wirklich eine
gute Sache ansonsten wie immer vielen
Dank fürs zuschauen und bleibt neugierig
euer CC